así después la alianza o incluso morena
por sí sola como bien lo comentan no
tiene ya mayoría simple en la cámara de
diputados y para llevar a cabo reformas
constitucionales necesitará forzosamente
no nada más aliarse con los partidos que
lo han acompañado sino también hacer
pactos con la oposición toda vez que
privan y pr de que es el bloque opositor
más movimientos ciudadanos que compitió
sólo reúnen 219 votos esto obligará al
partido en el poder a llegar a
negociaciones para poder sacar adelante
el presupuesto las reformas
constitucionales que el presidente
quiere entre ellas una pretendida
reducción de la autonomía de los órganos
como el instituto nacional electoral es
importante también mencionar que la
alianza pri-pan perredé anunció que no
nada más se quedaría en el terreno
electoral sino que iría a la arena
legislativa con esta con este pacto de
unión que tuvieron en estas elecciones
que
con una participación del 52%
hay que mencionar que comparar con la
anterior elección intermedia de 2015 fue
una participación incluso mayor claro
que si se compara con la elección
presidencial de 2018 no lo fue tanto
pero es siempre ocurre así es menor la
participación en las elecciones
intermedias de modo que pues ahora
tendrá que morena llegar a acuerdos
incluso con el partido verde que ha sido
su aliado y que en ocasiones ha puesto
sus diferencias con morena